[Applaudissements]
tour de table paramètres s'il a d'autres
2 oui ça on va voir qui aura la
meilleure jusqu'à arriver à bouder ces
partis monde ahmed la première était
parfait elle était bien moi j'adore on
enchaîne avec une blague petit accent
belge a déjà attention
jugez donc c'est c'est un groupe d'amis
tu vois un groupe d'amis au belge et ils
se connaissent depuis très très très
longtemps j'en ris on est ensemble
choisir à la naissance quoi dire ça va
trois manches travail donne un vrai
qu'ils se connaissent depuis qui perds
mon temps il en est ensuite tous dans le
groupe
ils se sont mariés il en manquait un et
vient juste de se marier c'est patrick
patrick qui vient de se marier et il a
fait sa nuit de noces est donc juste
après la nuit de noces le rituel c'est
que fini la nuit de noces ils se
retrouvent entre potes et craque une
bière donc ils sont là autour de tours
du marais tout il se raconte et non
machin et oussama ça va ça va ça va
alors patrick simard est entre-temps
c'est que j'ai mal à la gorge
patrick raconte puce annonce l'attendu
bien que freddy comment ça s'est passé
dit est la patrie
moi j'ai pas très écoutée manu de
mossoul où nous avait raconté mais moi
je trouve ça trop petit j'ai pas envie
très content émane d'une noce
robert est ouverte à majorer on
aboutisse il n'ose pas pourquoi toi tu
raconterai pas en 2012 patrick tu
racontes à une mousse je vous racontais
manu danse alors c'est très simple on
est arrivé dans la chambre
tu vois on arrivait dans la chambre des
pétales de rose partout on s'est
allongée tracts ils consomment peu de
champagne et verser le champagne sur le
corps et les cris tout excité là elle me
regarde et me dit fais moi l'amour fait
moi mourir est excité mais comme me
fonde c'est bien simple si j'avais voulu
me le faisait
[Applaudissements]
il débarque en terre de sa femme anna
j'ai compris tu vois ta combat et sa
femme et enfant chéri connais tu faisais
l'accent guinée n'était pas d'accord
mais c'est passé non c'est pas ça
j'écoute vraiment je suis du style à
écouter et en même temps je réfléchis à
ce que je vais pouvoir raconter comme la
suite dissiper parce que du coup je
n'écouterai et après le faire comprends
pas ce qui a dit quoi et pour qui a la
meilleure je vais vous dire il a mis la
barre bagnac l'udc est passé pour la
star genesta et bien c'est fait c'est
tout des fourmis qui tous les jours tous
les jours font leur petit rage elles
sont habituées de haut elles sont bien
leur donner parce qu'on connaît les
fourmis elles sont toujours comme ça et
tous les matins il ya monsieur et les
vents mais les faons qui se réveille qui
ces boules qui écrase le nid des fourmis
que tu as paf pape et les fournir son
ras-le-bol parce qu'à chaque fois
qu'elles font là mais tu as gros pato
qui recommence
elles ont un peu plus et tous les matins
recommence à bien un jour elles font un
conciliabule fait les filles venaient on
en a ras-le-bol de ce gros connard
ok on va l'attaquer et toutes les formes
ou crient elles sont toutes petites
comme ça et là matin monsieur les vents
sur le hall haut s'ébrouent comme ça ils
marcheraient fourmies et toutes les
formations dessus à l'attaqué elle mode
cher monsieur les failles legris fallu
le beauf kata mairie comme chez les
français le chatouille
alors est ce ce coup il rigole toutes
les formes yvan de quoi elle va un
moment donné il a une qui s'accrochent
comme ça un poil comme ça et tout ça
l'embêté cris
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gêné
[Applaudissements]
je
franchement meilleure attaque après
stationnaire
alors oui j'ai adoré tue quelqu'un qui
sait pas un conte les histoires je dis
bravo tu as we visuel les animaux et
tout j'aime bien alors on aime bien
j'étais une fourmi j'étais vu ses coûts
dans un trou c'est maurice bel hamon qui
s'est fait un plaisir des affaires
marchent bien mais sur un actif et ça
fera un voyage où sarah et abandonné sur
son chien bo comme ça tout gros de ce
seuil comme socialement au but ils
baladent le siège on puisse rebondissent
a fait le chapeau hyper bien et laissons
le charbon comme ça marie bellot et un
moment donné en plein soleil
il s'endort il se révèle une heure après
et ils voient qu'ils aient perdu seul
sur son chameau elle chameau une avancée
des [ __ ] mais chez eux où j'ai perdu
ton groupe c'est une catastrophe est où
est la remodeler le chameau et s'arrête
et légumes avance mais avance d'achat
pour qu'ils se retournent qui regarde
moi une belle en guinée donc je continue
mon film l'amour quoi chameau qui parle
c'est un truc de fou c'est quoi ça oui
continue je veux que tu continues avant
ça on s'en retrouve le groupe
méchamment il dit alors descend lève
macke et lèche - trop du but comme ça ne
te fait pas des chèques frauduleux
[Rires]
mais les informations ok c'est bien le
chameau qui parle et le léchage de paris
la prétention et remarques mesquines son
chapeau il s'arrête et digne mais avant
c'est à la mode il faut que je continue
le midi mais oui oui mais continuait
alors tu manques comme sa voisine du
target pas faire ça tu veux que je
continue tu ne fais moins semaine à
mouiller décent et n'en peut plus il
arrive à mourir de soif il à chaud et où
il est chapeau il remonte sa mort le
chameau la banque
ben oui c'est d'abord ça ça valait le
coup y est on ne donne jamais mais
comment savoir un groupe très très loin
très très loin et c'est pas bon je veux
moi je vais moi je les vois une charrue
s'arrête net
amorim anonymes avancent le chamonix il
faut que je continue a dit tu descends
tu me lève là que je me laisse le trou
du cul maurice belay mi-décembre la
caméra mode sur le chameau chamand il
avance et au bout de dix minutes
il s'arrête donc je continue
oui
[Applaudissements]
ça nous a menés là